okay let's get into audience questions
for the week starting with
what do you think would be trump's most
likely october surprises to try to win
the election
so before we get into this there's a con
there's a the idea is common
that october surprises don't really work
i'm not so sure about that if you look
at james comey's decision to do a second
hillary clinton press briefing uh at the
very tail end of the 2016 election i
mean there were so many factors that
affected that election but it's hard to
say that that had no
impact when you look at george w bush's
bin laden
uh speech and announcements right before
the 2004 election in which he was
narrowly re-elected arguably with a
small victory in the state of ohio
although there were some allegations of
foul play there in ohio
i don't know that we can write off an
october surprise now that being said
when more people vote by mail early
it does diminish the possible impact of
an october surprise
changing the outcome of any state for
example or of the the
total election because there are fewer
people left to vote right the more if 50
vote before october 15 and it's not
going to happen but imagine
then what happens between october 15 in
the election can only possibly impact
half of the electorate
instead of the entire thing now all of
that being put aside
um i still think that an announcement
about a vaccine
from donald trump sometime in october is
going to be
the the move so to speak and i've
already said
if indeed a vaccine is approved in
october and
let's not you know there are people who
write to me and they say if
there is a vaccine approved in october i
would be worried it's not really safe
that's not really my concern i don't
think trump is going to announce a
vaccine that's not actually been
approved
i think trump's going to try to take
credit for that vaccine announcement
when it will have nothing whatever
to do with him it could be a vaccine
developed
in the uk for example the oxford vaccine
which is being discussed
it could be a vaccine that has been
around or in development for some time
for poultry coronavirus which has now
been modified which could be the one i
that doesn't seem like it but the point
is none of it would have anything to do
with donald trump
and yet he will announce it as if it is
his accomplishment and i fear
i used the term monday some people liked
it i fear that because of the portion of
the audience that's
intellectually compromised i fear it
could actually swing
a little bit of the vote so that's my
top if you say
what would you bet on if you had to bet
on what the october surprise would be
it would be trump trying to take credit
for a vaccine or
some kind of really effective treatment
for example if one is found
beyond that you know there's the the old
faithful ideas
of some kind of conflict this is kind of
chaos pr
usually it's a foreign conflict that's
used
to justify re-electing the president we
have not changing horses midstream
with trump he seems to think that it's
generating chaos
within american cities that is going to
be good for him
and whether he would scale that up in
october we don't know whether it
actually helps him is not really clear i
think it's certainly possible that it
activates
some of his key constituents but we are
going to have to wait on that
now again it could i mentioned
earlier that there's going to be more of
mainland voting
absentee ballots than there typically
are and that could reduce the power of a
possible
october surprise the other side of it is
that
messing with the voting itself could be
the october surprise it wouldn't
necessarily
be done in public although hopefully we
would figure it out
the trouble with trump lying all the
time
is that no one believes you eventually
and thus there could be the possibility
that trump comes up with some new
obama gate or trump makes a claim about
a virus treatment or whatever
and nobody will care because nobody will
believe it or at least not enough people
will miracle cure you know who knows
what it could be
the real surprise would be
him figuring out a way to secretly mess
with the election that we don't detect
and the surprise is everybody thinks
there's no surprise when in reality he's
finding new and novel ways to mess with
the election
that's what i'm most scared of followed
by just taking credit for a vaccine
and some people actually giving him
credit for it